a red sky in New York the smirk is
drifting from Canada where wildfires
have been burning out of control for
weeks the haze is now sweeping across
the border to the United States
this is the view from space the trail
can be seen drifting across Northern and
eastern U.S states millions of people
are being warned of the dangers over 50
percent of the US population everything
East of Columbus Ohio is experiencing
levels on the order of 150 to 180 which
is an air quality index suggesting that
these are very hazardous levels to be
breathing but it's far worse in Canada
where there are more than 400 wildfires
burning thousands of people have been
moved to safety from their homes western
United States has seen it quite drupling
of area Burns since the 1970s Canada has
seen a doubling a barrier Burns since
the early 70s and this is largely not
solely but largely attributed to
human-caused climate change forecasters
expect the fires to increase in number
and intensify this month putting Canada
on course for its War West wildfest
season on record Barbara and gopa Al
Jazeera